happy Monday everybody what a great
Monday it is
going to be a big show because it's the
first Gutfeld super duper journalism
Awards
[Music]
I don't know
so this is where we honor writers who
impress us with their Brave journalistic
Pursuits and tonight's winner we get
right to it Jeremy Bailey a writer for
the rap and entertainment website on
Friday last week he broke a major story
about a famous TV anchor saying
something shockingly disgusting to a
co-anchor I believe we have tape of what
actually caused the Uproar
a lot of these homeless services that
are getting a lot of money more and more
money it's not working the solution is
in listening to the homeless like the
woman who says we are spoiled we need
tough love or we're never going to get
off the street
Greg what do you think about that
approach I agree with everything the
little lady says and I'm sorry about the
cart
now did you catch that
panelist Greg Gutfeld otherwise known as
me referred to Dana Perino as a little
lady and talk about a microaggression
here's a quote from Bailey in the rap
Perino and Gutfeld often trade witty
barbs and banter but Perino is also a
veteran news anchor whose career dates
to a stint as the White House Press
Secretary during the GW Bush
Administration while it took her a beat
to register gutfeld's reference to her
as the little lady she laughed it off
and she continued
now you think that I just told Dana to
take off her shoes and get in the
kitchen where she belongs
which by the way is what I say to Jesse
every day
to respond
is quote unfazed yes unfazed like she's
a war reporter continuing a live hit
while bombs are raining down
what an ass so what was she supposed to
do fly into a raid slap me across the
face even when she knows how much I like
that
so why doesn't she care well the
reporter could have answered it himself
if he knew the topic he was writing
about but that would require
journalistic ability
so why should she be unfazed would she
be unfazed over being called a little
lady she flunky you must be tall sign at
an end
stuffer an oven mitt is her
sleeping bag and nothing slows her down
except for glue traps and I've seen
Chihuahuas carry her in their purses and
always make sure she's not in your
pocket before you wash your pants and
her above ground pool is an empty Cool
Whip container she was the bride
figurine on her own wedding cake and her
pronouns are teeny tiny and itsy bitsy
and she's always picked first for limbo
and she's used to being under the
microscope when having her clothes
tailored she goes sledding on a pink
eraser she proves good things come in
small packages especially when she's
smuggling heroin
breaking news a woman can take a joke
anyway not deterred by this sorted
history the writer knowing had the scoop
of his lifetime actually reached out to
Fox our company for comment and that
right to our gut field our Gutfeld
complaint department
Hey Joe we got another request for
comment I really need you to take care
of this all right
I'll get right on this thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so uh the wrap expected Dana to be
offended and they decided they would be
offended for her as well but how
offended was she really well we go to
Dana for comment hey Jeremy if you think
that's offensive you should hear what I
call Greg in private like how he's a no
Talent
chicken full of horse I've got more
talent in my book than he does in his
entire book and just being around that
makes me want to all over the floor I
mean I know squirrels with bigger than
him do I need to go on oh wow
clap oh you clap for that now being fair
and balanced unafraid and also gorgeous
we went to Jeremy for a comment right
because that would be fair yes we
actually reached out for a comment on
him needing to reach out for a comment
and we tried to review his other writing
to see if it's parody Or if he's always
this stupid
here's the actual email we sent and so
far there's been no response so what a
perfect microcosm of the current
journalism landscape people who don't
know what they're talking about trying
to create a scandal off a single
throwaway line that that's journalism
but it's not just them Yahoo news
reprinted the story and I know what
you're thinking what's Yahoo news
but there's a whole ecosystem of stupid
Lefty takes it's like a terrarium except
the reptiles are even uglier hell look
at this headline for Media Matters just
a few weeks ago Fox News Greg Gutfeld
calls for the arrest of Dr Jill as
payback for the indictment of Donald
Trump
again they wouldn't know a joke even if
it started with the words knock knock
here's the clip they were so offended by
I'm not that interested in locking up
Hunter or Joe Biden but the other side
would lock up every one of us if they
could so let's go you almost let's F and
go let's take them out let's put him
behind bars all of them police
Dr Jill I want she's not a real doctor
how long has she been practicing on
patience telling them that she's an
actual doctor
[Laughter]
I guess you can't tell when someone's
joking if you have no sense of humor but
that got picked up by these hacks who
realized they can't write what they
really want to write if they admit that
it's a joke so instead they lie to their
viewers or their readers but you can see
how nothing matters when your filter is
preconceived and you're desperate for
Content it doesn't make you a journalist
it just makes you a whole filler wake up
fill a hole go home cry yourself to
sleep you know you'd be a lot happier if
you worked on potholes at least there
you'd have something to be proud of at
the end of the day and this ain't it
Jeremy
[Applause]
he was on SNL before it stood for sorry
no laughs comedian and host of the new
Fox Asian setup says I woke up in
America Rob Schneider
these got the mind of a newsman and the
face of an even better looking newsman
America's Newsroom co-anchor Bill Hammer
he's the Rebel Rouser with a face like
Doogie Howser oh so the guy bets at show
Guy Benson
cheese wiry fiery and has a tear stain
diary Fox's contributor captive
so Rob I'm trying to figure out what
kind of connotation is there to little
lady that I somehow missed I mean can
you imagine being watching that and
deciding that this is a journal this is
a story that requires following up on as
I just think of three three-fifths of
this group we have here are all insulted
by what you did yeah no I
as Dana was a until this whole
episode
I think we call them little people now
well I I don't know you know what though
is interesting is that you know little
people live a lot longer yeah you know
what you never hear the NBA best seven
foot basketball player turned 100 today
yeah it's true he didn't hear that
they're already tight they're always
tiny people you know why yeah I think
it's because you know you don't you take
these smaller steps you know so there's
no science there no no not at all Hammer
you're a journalist yes you claim to be
one does this embarrass you I mean you
had some you I'm sure you had to do some
pretty bad stories but this feels like
you a story you don't you know what I
thought was offensive was the way you
motioned with your right thumb for just
one split millisecond I mean that was
the offensive why now why is that effect
I just saw it in the replay and I saw
the write-up on and I thought well he's
on to something
do you think this was a a subliminal
alt-right symbol that I was doing with
my aunt oh now that only you can answer
that I'm saying it's a signal maybe
you're on to self I work with Dana every
day yeah yeah and she's convinced she's
taller than you no she's she does
[Applause]
some people are convinced they're like
the wrong gender I mean that's she has
if she wants to identify as five seven
that's her right but she's four eleven
no it's it's like an old joke of mine I
said like uh my parents are short and I
married a girl shorter than me we're
like Shetland people we're breeding down
she also wouldn't need to be five seven
to be taller than you why you need to be
like five five why is this turning into
an attack on me didn't we have this
already the argument already on Friday
what were you here on Friday yeah you're
always here yes
we did an entire round on my height I'm
always here and you've said way worse
stuff to me than that every single day
yeah why does Yahoo news never get upset
on my behalf because you're not a vet I
would love to be called little lady it's
always like mentally ill alcoholic
scarecrow
I don't know but this is actually not as
bad as some other things I've seen too I
remember in like 2015
uh the salon did something about me
where they referred to me as an outraged
parent or administrator
of which I'm neither and they could have
didn't even have to Google it they could
have just rewounded the clip that they
were posting to see how I'm introduced
but they don't care it's so lazy because
people they're like oh everybody hates
Fox News anyway so nobody will care
that's what they think and they also
realize nobody's gonna check to see if
somebody was making a joke so they'll
say like oh he like the the one about me
saying that Dr Jill should be in prison
was taken seriously by so many people
and it's because they didn't but they
don't watch the clip either they just
read the headline guy I'm sure you had
some like an entry-level reporting jobs
did you ever do anything like this I
mean I feel bad that somebody has to do
that for a living well you actually
avoided the key crime here which was not
calling her doctor you were very good
about doing that yes the other thing is
for people who may not fully understand
at home what Media Matters is yeah it's
this group of left Wingers paid by
somebody to sit chained to a radiator
somewhere watching us all day long
trying to find things to get angry about
this is their entire existence they sit
there like Clockwork Orange they're
eyeballs but their eyes open full of
them yeah they all sit in this little
hive mind and I'm convinced that at
least at some point in our history we
have converted one of these Media
Matters people into liking us because we
are irresistible that's why they stop so
they say a lot of these people and it's
not just them but The Daily Beast does
it these other places they they you're
not like exaggerating this people are
paid to watch this show because the
clips and the five and this show the
clips generate eyeballs and that pays
for their advertising so it's actually
like Barnacles on a ship like you all
you got to do is create this ship and
then you create jobs for all these other
people at some point when someone starts
to have impure thoughts about Fox News
because they actually they have to watch
us all the time and they realize
actually we we kind of like this it's
off to the gulag and they find the next
person out of college I think that's how
the system works over there yeah well I
think you're correct and I'm not going
to call you a little lady
[Laughter]
know what that means I still don't know
what I want a little lady what's wrong
with it cat you're a woman
because because thank you
um because
she's had a long impressive professional
career but also I feel like if you're
able to handle being a press secretary
for the president you're able to handle
being called that yeah now that's not
bad little lady see what I did there the
rap is all over this side
all right we gotta move on coming up
brain dead politicians making bad
decisions hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else